our rate if i'm just going by our rate
of technological improvement is drastic
every decade and for sure every century
so some people would
critique every decade like peter thiel
but at least every century that's for
sure
and when you take a look at let's
imagine these aliens are going back to
their planet
that takes a couple years it from some
other
time frame it'll take it'll it may take
them a proper time they can do it on a
few
depending on their accelerations it
could be a few days to a few months
um for for us it could take it for us it
could take
a thousand years or 100 couple hundred
years so yeah
so let's just imagine they're going back
to their little alien civilization
in some other planet okay then i would
imagine that that planet
has increased its age by maybe a few
decades
then i would imagine that when they come
back they should be far
more technologically advanced each so
every decade for us when they're going
and coming back presuming they're going
and coming back
i don't see why it should look the same
at all because i would imagine that if
it was us
we would look vastly different every
century or so especially
century from now maybe our planes look
like triangles maybe a century
from maybe 200 years from now our planes
would look like dust
and then maybe farther it'll look like a
planet and so on you understand the idea
yeah so why do you think it is that
there's somewhat of a constancy
of the reports in terms of how they look
a visual inspection maybe even their
speed
of aliens given that we are so
quick with our technological advancement
and they are presumably far more
advanced than us
which means their trajectory of let's
say moore's law or whatever it is that
they follow
should be they should be farther along
in the exponential curve
no that's an excellent that's an
excellent question and i
have a hypothesis that could answer that
in it
and i came up with this in response
to the general reaction
of so so so it's we we
we know well that if you can get a craft
up to
um relativistic speeds if you could
engineer something like this
so yes huge engineering fee whatever we
don't even know how you'd pull it off
whatever
yeah but if you could then time dilation
works
in your favor it works in the favor of
the traveler right
so so you could you could conceivably
leave your home world let's say you come
from a thousand light years away
you leave your home world and you travel
to earth and
you can travel close to the speed of
light
so you can get here in a few weeks so
it's a few week trip to earth that's
nice for you
um it will be it'll take about a
thousand years if if that planet's a
thousand light years away from earth
it'll take a thousand years in the
galaxy frame so a thousand years will
pass on earth and a thousand years will
pass at home
and then now they hang out here they go
into you know they land in a meadow and
and
chose that on purpose um and take some
biological samples and then they take
off and head home
now on the way home it's another
thousand light years
so for us in the galaxy's frame it's
going to take another thousand years
for them to get home um
maybe a couple weeks for them again so
for them what it was a
you know a few month trip um has turned
into a 2000 year trip back at home
and the argument you know while while
relativity would work in favor of the
traveler the question is who would do
that
because what society would ever conceive
of a mission that would take 2 000 years
because
the people who designed the mission are
never going to see the results of it
and the travelers are going to come back
to a culture that's totally different
than the culture they left because
of the the um
reasons that you're stating so so why
would anyone do this well
the the supposition is that they are
going to go home um and that they live
on a planet and i think that's
you know that that's what we have
implicitly assumed there
what we've neglected to remember is that
even on earth
there exists nomadic tribes and there's
still exist nomadic tribes
so you could pull this off if you were
a nomadic society not a planet-bound
society
so imagine you know you and me we want
to go space
traveling but we don't want to be 10 you
know a thousand years apart
um i'll head off to um
to the star rigel or something 900 light
years away you pick another
place to go about about as distant and
we plan to meet back up here
at you know a certain time in the future
so we can plan our trip accordingly so
that we come back here at the same time
and it may be 2 000 years in earth's
future but
you know we don't care we can still meet
up and compare notes and then we can
travel off again
so you can imagine that you could have a
whole breakaway civilization like this
where it literally is a civil
civilization of travelers
and that's what they do they travel and
they travel and they explore
and they periodically meet up they have
meetup points
and meetup times that are all
pre-arranged or they have some algorithm
for this
and um they can then exchange goods they
can exchange
information and travel again and what
they're basically doing is they're using
relativity in their favor
using time dilation in their favor and
they're basically
but but they're not just space traveling
they're also time traveling into the
future right
so they're they're traveling through
space interstellar space but they're
also traveling through time
by racing forward into the future with
respect to the rest of the galaxy
so all of them and their friends are
also traveling around
to meet up at the same two thousand year
future
relative to the galaxy yeah they might
not they might not have a single meet up
place they might have multiple meet-up
places and just randomly meet up but
yeah you could do it various ways
and if that was the situation then you
could take advantage of relativity to
travel
you know galactic distances
and um and
the advantages i mean it would be very
interesting because
you could um so imagine that you
accelerate you know what a thousand if
you could accelerated a thousand g
like you know similar to some of these
objects we've observed
you could accelerate at a thousand g
halfway decelerated 1000g the other half
you can get from one side of the galaxy
to the other in just a couple
weeks a couple months um so
so let's say it takes you three months
to get from one side of the galaxy to
the other
and then you can come back and when you
come back it's
taking you a six month trip but you know
in the galaxy's frame it's going to be
about a hundred thousand years later
so you get to travel through time and
and so now your perspective of the
universe is very different
um first when you first
when people look at you they're going to
see the same ships
you're traveling in the same craft and
why do these craft not evolve
because it's actually the same one it
could actually be the same craft
so the same craft that was observed in
roman times
could literally be the same object with
the same
you know beings in it you know two
thousand years later
they could literally be the same option
fascinating fascinating
fascinating so let's imagine this is a
10-day journey for them
and for them for them it's a couple days
yeah so they would be
so they might be very now for them we
are
ephemeral right and um
because they're when they come back you
and i are going to be gone so
there's no point in making friends
there's no point in landing on the white
house law and introducing yourself to
the president
because the next time they come back the
united states isn't even going to be
here
it'll be something else another culture
so there's no point in getting to know
the locals
you